[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
el presente y en el futuro para hablar
de las lecciones que hemos aprendido de
toda esta crisis sanitaria para ello me
acompañan en este estudio john ward
cortinas muñoz sociólogo del instituto
de ciencias políticas de parís experto
en políticas de salud bienvenido joan
cráter carlos luisa corradini
corresponsal del diario la nación
bienvenida luis sánchez desde barcelona-
el profesor jeffrey lázarus profesor
asociado en la universidad de barcelona
y del instituto de salud global buenos
días señor lázarus
buenos días con las gracias lecciones de
la comida hoy en primera plana
[Música]
ya saben eso que dicen de que las crisis
son oportunidades para crecer para
emerger del nuevo caos con un nuevo
orden y lo estamos viendo durante esta
pandemia estamos hablando del cambio
climático de la cooperación
internacional de los vulnerables que
somos son campos que están en la
reflexión que están encima de la mesa
para ver qué conclusiones sacamos pues
para futuras pandemias para nuestro
futuro como sociedad la pregunta es lo
haremos con éxito sabremos sacar las
buenas consecuencias de esta pandemia es
nuestro punto de partida en el programa
de hoy pero antes de preguntar a
nuestros invitados vamos a reflexionar a
partir de unas portadas de prensa como
siempre revista newsweek esta epidemia
es una llamada para despertarse el
coronavirus dice la publicación muestra
todas nuestras vulnerabilidades la
revista alemana wirtschaftswoche
consagra su portada card marx con
mascarilla con un interesante
planteamiento bajo el título 'el siempre
acaba volviendo dice la revista economía
salud sociedad la pandemia vuelve a
rescatar postulados de la izquierda al
centro del debate social
esta otra portada de la revista 'time'
está protagonizada por una anestesista
italiano con un titular que ya llevamos
que ya vamos asumiendo tenemos que
aceptar que nuestras vidas ya han
cambiado definitivamente algo a lo que
se suma también el semanario italiano
l'espresso subrayando que la pandemia ha
cambiado absolutamente todo bueno johann
esta es la primera lección que sacamos
de la pandemia que aquella normalidad
que estuvimos evocando durante la
primera ola nunca llegará a ser la misma
a ver depende espero que sí en nuestras
vidas cotidianas en tanto que individuos
ahí donde espero que cambien las cosas a
un nivel más colectivo a nivel
estructural es decir la organización de
nuestras sociedades económica política y
socialmente que son estructuras y
maneras de funcionar que la pandemia
como dicen estas portadas ha revelado
que no funcionan porque no funcionan
porque nos han llevado la situación en
la que estamos actualmente es decir la
naturaleza ha venido para recordarnos
que no podemos desconectarnos y que
tenemos la relación recíproca con esa
naturaleza y eso hay que tomarlo en
cuenta y reestructurar nuestras maneras
de funcionar a ese nivel
luisa cuáles son las principales
lecciones que sacamos como sociedad de
este fatídico año yo no sé si la
sociedad va a sacar lecciones yo creo
que hay sectores de la sociedad que
sacarán seguramente elecciones como por
ejemplo el sector político los
dirigentes los dirigentes van a aprender
cantidad de cosas en europa
específicamente los dirigentes
descubrieron que era una locura
deslocalizar por ejemplo las industrias
sanitarias industria formación
las industrias del medicamento de
primera necesidad y esto lo aprendieron
la unióneuropea aprendió que no podía no
estar adentro de las competencias de la
unión europea' el sistema de salud por
ejemplo las políticas sanitarias
esto también lo aprendieron y
naturalmente cada gobierno aprendió
cosas específicas que la gente en
general haya aprendido cosas y yo no lo
sé veremos después de la pandemia la
historia de las pandemias demuestra que
la gente muy rápidamente se olvidó de
las lecciones que había aprendido y
volvió a hacer una vida totalmente
inconsciente arriesgada y peligrosa
le voy a trasladar también la pregunta
al profesor es difícil hacerlos desde
barcelona el profesor lanza los cuáles
son las principales lecciones que
podemos extraer de este año fatídico uno
de los desafíos más importantes sigue
siendo la colaboración la unión europea
tiene que tomar decisiones conjuntamente
sobre qué vacunas se van a utilizar por
ejemplo sobre las restricciones de
viajar entre países
otras medidas de control como las zonas
verdes para ir abriendo partes de los
países lo que hemos aprendido es que ni
la unión europea ni el nuestro del mundo
sea un país rico o un país pobre está
preparado para una pandemia no sabemos
cómo colaborar y la solera vedad está
totalmente ausente y para la sociedad
hemos visto la falta de confianza las
autoridades y su inhabilidad de poder
explicar bien las medidas de control la
lección principal para los gobiernos es
comunicar mejor con la población
o luisa la recurrencia de las epidemias
y las zoonosis que lo llaman los
científicos en los últimos años nos
explica sin las transformaciones
medioambientales
lakovic ser vida de impulso en la lucha
contra el cambio climático ojalá ojalá
porque justamente esta kobe como tú
dices no nos nos revelan o que somos
interdependientes con nuestro medio
ambiente no hay una frontera entre
nosotros la naturaleza al contrario esta
semana hemos tenido dos elementos
importantes que nos pueden responder a
esta pregunta uno ha sido el parlamento
europeo una decisión que dice cuáles son
las líneas a seguir para limitar las
emisiones de co2 y ayer una cumbre
climática en donde baiden reúne a los
líderes del mundo para decir cómo vamos
a hacerlo las pistas que empiezan a
apropiar perfilarse no son muy buenas
porque porque se confía mucho la
tecnología en los coches eléctricos
los aviones con hidrógeno es la
tecnología la que nos va a sacar de esta
situación no yo creo que eso es un error
o en todo caso la tecnología no es
suficiente porque lo que hay que cambiar
es nuestra relación con el medio
ambiente es esta frontera está
tenemos que nosotros existimos
independientemente la naturaleza y es lo
contrario somos absolutamente
dependientes o interdependientes por lo
tanto mi opinión es que de momento no
vamos por el buen camino si contamos con
la tecnología como única solución para
dar respuesta a las sociedades de riesgo
las que vivimos vamos por mal camino
aviso hacer la tecnología que expone
yoani la cob y deja al descubierto
también las fragilidades de un mundo muy
interconectado de la globalización creen
en un replanteamiento luisa de una
economía más local y más sostenible a
partir de ahora me parece que la gente
ha tomado conciencia de eso pero
nosotros somos unos privilegiados que
vivimos en el ombligo del mundo entonces
los europeos las sociedades que tienen
que son desarrolladas que tienen medios
pueden darse el lujo de decir nosotros
vamos a dejar de contaminar vamos a
cambiar nuestros hábitos cotidianos
vamos a ir a un consumo local etcétera
etcétera qué va a pasar con el resto del
mundo qué va a pasar con países como
china india
áfrica que son países que tienen otras
necesidades imperiosas las donde la
gente tiene además necesidades
elementales como como hoy y mañana que
no tienen agua que no tienen servicios
públicos que no tiene electricidad este
es el problema como se hace cuál es a mí
me parece que es un trabajo inmenso yo
no estoy tan segura de que el mundo esté
en condiciones y estoy totalmente de
acuerdo con lo que acaba de decir yo que
es que la gente los dirigentes de los
grandes países desarrollados hayan
tomado conciencia de cuál es el camino
realmente para cambiar este modo de
consumo que nos lleva realmente a la
catástrofe nena en un interesantísimo
artículo que ha escrito el profesor
jeffrey lázarus junto a un grupo de
expertos lancet cobit de 19 salud
pública estás fors apelan a que las
variantes atención han alterado
completamente el juego contra el virus y
que no estaremos tranquilos hasta que no
exista una supresión
máxima del virus porque las vacunas ya
puede que no sean suficientes porque es
tan importante profesor lázarus esa
supresión total ya hemos visto que hay
mutaciones más transmisibles más
virulentos que hay que asegurar que
protegemos a individuos a la población
en general y el sistema sanitario la
supresión máxima es tan importante
porque hay que evitar que variantes de
preocupación y ya hay tres identificados
y se multiplican si las vacunas no nos
protejan de síntomas severas tenemos un
problema muy muy serio johann una
pandemia demuestra que el riesgo es
sistémico y por tanto que es
imprescindible expandir la protección
social a más capas de la sociedad como a
laporta que enfrentado es divertido a la
vuelta de calzón ex no
bueno pues básicamente lo que decía
también luisa la cuestión medioambiental
la cuestión vírica no está no se puede
desconectar de la cuestión social como
lo hemos visto por ejemplo hemos visto
que durante 20 años hemos tiene un
discurso sobre la austeridad en la
economía
de la salud pública diciendo no podemos
gastar tanto en salud pública que ha
pasado ha llegado una pandemia que nos
ha demostrado que sin salud pública
nuestra sociedad no sólo se para sino
que corre el riesgo de desaparecer no
entonces si la salud pública
evidentemente tiene que ser un pilar
central de nuestras sociedades porque es
un bien común que sólo el estado puede
asegurar algo en el mercado las clínicas
privadas no pueden hacerlo por lo tanto
hay que expandir la seguridad social a
todo el mundo si hay que asegurar los
esenciales es decir lo común a todos los
ciudadanos evidentemente yo creo que la
pandemia no deja ninguna duda entre ese
vínculo entre la sociedad y el riesgo y
la cuestión social antes se refería la
señora corradine a esa diferenciación
entre países ricos y pobres quizá ahora
en la campaña de vacunación sí que
estamos entendiendo que por mucho que
dispongamos los países ricos de esas
vacunas hasta que no lleguen al último
rincón del mundo no vamos a estar
protegidos al cien por cien que es un
poco también la teoría del señor lázarus
de supresión máxima pero por supuesto
pero además fíjate en el nivel de
impreparación en el fondo por qué
europa la unión europea es un espacio
tradicionalmente solidario y generoso e
inmediatamente después de la pandemia
apoyó la creación del sistema kóvacs que
depende de la organización mundial de la
salud para poder llevar las vacunas a
los países más desfavorecidos
pues europa no tiene ella misma las
vacunas porque por su preparación no
puede producirlas en europa sabemos no
vamos a evocar todo ese conflicto que
hubo con con la falta de vacunas a
disposición de europa a pesar de que les
había comprado entonces si no tiene
vacunas para sí misma como va a ser para
distribuirlas al resto del mundo esto es
un problema que hay que resolver pero
cómo se resuelve
yo creo que esas son lecciones que
quedarán para la próxima pandemia y
espero que no tengamos que ponerlas en
práctica pero en este momento es un
problema extremadamente serio para
resolver que no se va a resolver en 3 ó
4 años cómo se vacuna a toda la
población mundial ante una ausencia
total de vacunas son necesarias vamos a
tener este punto una breve pausa y a la
vuelta les quiero preguntar sobre
consecuencias políticas de la pandemia
por ejemplo miraremos a partir de ahora
más los ciudadanos los programas
sanitarios de los políticos que se
presenten a futuras elecciones se
planteó a vuelta de pausa
descubra las historias de la gente con
nuestros reporteros por todo el planeta
cada semana reporteros le trae una
historia inédita acompáñenos en
reporteros en cada semana por france 24
y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas france24 puntocom liberté
égalité actualice
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana hablando esta
semana de elecciones que sacamos de esta
pandemia para quizá gestionar futuras
pandemias lo hacemos con johann cortinas
muñoz sociólogo del instituto de
ciencias políticas de parís luisa
corradini corresponsal del diario la
nación y en dúplex desde barcelona-el
profesor jeffrey lázarus del instituto
de salud global en europa luisa nos
llevamos las manos a la cabeza recuerdo
durante la primera ola cuando
descubrimos que no teníamos mascarillas
suficientes ni material médico porque
habíamos deslocalizado fábricas fuera de
nuestras fronteras somos conscientes de
que anclar industrias básicas en los
sistemas locales es una lección
aprendida yo creo que sí absolutamente
esa es una de las lecciones más claras
que
que deben haber aprendido los dirigentes
por lo menos lo reclaman pero sobre todo
la gente la opinión pública antes decía
el hospital tiene que estar mejor
provisto tienen que tener más medios
etcétera pero esto no era un elemento
que pesaba en el proceso electoral el
electoral ahora sí yo estoy
absolutamente convencida de que la gente
va a ser muy exigente por lo menos en
europa y creo que en el resto del mundo
también van ahora a partir de ahora
sería si llegara otra pandemia yo
imagino que la gente no podría tolerar
esa escasez de ciertas industrias
básicas en su territorio no bueno es una
cuestión bien compleja y enigmática la
política es un arte muy misterioso no es
decir
yo quiero creer que sí pero la verdad si
te soy sincero no lo sé es una cuestión
que se pone en el centro de los
discursos pero repito son discursos y ya
veremos a largo plazo si la memoria nos
acompaña segundo una cuestión para mí
que es inquietante en el tema político
es que ha habido un aumento del
conspiracionismo bueno hemos todo lo
visto durante esta pandemia
los complotistas el complot esa esfera
esa manera de ver la realidad de
deformar la ha tomado mucho peso ha
tomado mucha importancia no sólo porque
ha habido los medios que lo han lo han
transmitido sino porque realmente han
tomado mucho peso a mí me preocupa
especialmente es este este este aspecto
es decir porque esto está aumentando en
en una situación en la que todo el mundo
con sentido común tendría que decir hay
que volver a los sistemas públicos de
salud y cómo se puede comer podemos
explicar que justamente sea lo contrario
gente que sigue negando la epidemia que
dice eso sólo me lo han inventado los
chinos y ese movimiento que está
aumentando muchísimo y está seguido por
partidos que emergen en todo en todos
los países hay que hay que ir con mucho
cuidado cómo hacemos para evitar que eso
siga creciendo no y ahí está para mí el
reto y el desafío de los partidos
políticos de la clase pues les
preguntaba por lecciones de la primera
parte de la pandemia de ese material que
faltaba vayamos a lecciones de esta
última parte qué errores hemos cometido
en la campaña de vacunación sobre todo
aquí en europa
se ha hablado mucho de los puntos
fuertes y débiles de la unión europea
respecto
si hubo errores en las campañas de
vacunación hubo errores ser seguramente
en la negociación para la obtención de
vacunas es decir el grupo inocente
mira yo la europa no podía ser otra cosa
más que hacer esas compras agrupadas
para los 27 países del bloque eso
naturalmente porque de lo contrario
francia hubiera sido beneficiada
alemania hubiera sido beneficiada a los
grandes países pero por el contrario los
pequeños países del bloque nunca
hubieran obtenido las vacunas o hubieran
tenido que pagar fortunas eso estaba muy
bien lo que probablemente sucedió con el
caso de la unión europea es que pecó de
inocencia porque no tuvo en cuenta que
había vacunas que se producían en el
territorio europeo como por ejemplo el
caso de fai serbio antes que en alemania
no hizo como los ingleses o como los
americanos que dijeron bueno muy bien
nosotros financiamos y ponemos dinero
para que ustedes produzcan esas vacunas
pero la prioridad es nuestra entonces
nos encontramos con esos problemas que
hubo por ejemplo con astrazéneca que se
producían esas vacunas en europa pero
que como gran bretaña había puesto esa
cláusula en el contrato recibía las
vacunas antes eeuu y eso exactamente lo
mismo entonces esos fueron los errores
los errores iniciales pero porque yo
creo que ningún dirigente político
actual se imaginó y eso está mal eso es
otro error que nos íbamos a encontrar en
una pandemia semejante es decir yo creo
y johann lo debes saber mejor que yo que
dentro de todo programa de gobierno hay
una previsión de pandemias entonces qué
fue lo que pasó eso es lo que hay que
mirar
profesor lazarus las dudas surgidas en
las últimas semanas hablando de la
campaña de vacunación con las vacunas
con astrazéneca y con esta última de
johnson and johnson tenemos claro que
más riesgos en saliendo a la calle que
poniéndote una de las vacunas que
hablamos de casos muy marginales de
trombos y que el ratio riesgo-beneficio
es muy favorable a las vacunas entonces
le pregunto no han sido responsables de
los gobiernos frenando en seco las
campañas de vacunación sabiendo que
podían acrecentar el escepticismo y
perder un tiempo de oro
entiendo que había que frenar para
investigar los pocos casos de eventos
adversos causados por dos de las vacunas
aprobadas pero al determinar que eran
eventos muy muy muy raros
teníamos que haber redimensionado su uso
más rápido y extenso
tal como se recomienda la agencia
europea de medicamentos los gobiernos de
los eeuu de la unión europea y
especialmente y dinamarca que había
parado para siempre el uso de la vacuna
estrogénica hasta que cambiaron la
decisión el lunes pasado han hecho mucho
daño en mi opinión en términos de
confianza las vacunas
joan se perdió mucho tiempo en estos al
menos creció el escepticismo hace las
vacunas por frenar así una campaña
cuando se está diciendo que el ratio
beneficio está claramente favorable a
las vacunas porque parece que es un
mensaje contradictorio cuanto menos
bueno es un mensaje contradictorio no sé
el tema digamos en este caso
evidentemente se dio que ir muy rápido
para dar una respuesta a una pandemia no
en ese en ese ir muy rápido se han
acelerado procesos que normalmente
tardan mucho mucho más tiempo entonces
evidentemente yo creo que es la reacción
relativamente normal la población es
escéptica con procesos que toman mucho
tiempo que sabemos todos que haría muy
rápido no entonces para mí no es muy
trascendental a mí el problema de las
vacunas como decía luis hoyos y lo veo
es que de nuevo no quiero ser pesimista
pero en que lo veo así no es decir no
hemos aprendido mucho es decir que pasa
la pandemia nos ha demostrado que una
industria farmacéutica casi
monopolística es decir controlada por
cuatro o cinco empresas no permite hacer
frente a una pandemia no porque vayamos
lentos no porque haya problemas con los
trombos sino
no tiene la capacidad productiva para
todo el mundo y cómo y por qué no la
tienen porque hay patentes que hacen que
esas vacunas no puedan ser producidas
por el máximo número de empresas y eso
tampoco lo hemos puesto en cuestión
decimos bueno hay que esperar porque las
no pueden producir los pobres y es que
son cuatro como a producir para para
ocho mil millones de personas no
entonces para mí otra elección
si hablamos de elecciones es que hay que
replantearnos cómo organizamos el
sistema donde producción de medicamentos
en situaciones de crisis que van a ser
permanentes podemos seguir contando con
4 lavatorios farmacéuticos de nivel
mundial para producir vacunas y
medicamentos para todo el mundo
bueno ahí dejo la pregunta vamos
avanzando con más lecciones en el campo
del periodismo hablamos de vacunas de
ciencia de luchar contra el escepticismo
pero para todo ello la función de
informar se antoja clave
luisa hay un despertar al hecho de que
el exceso de información sin verificar
intoxique genera problemas adicionales
es decir el periodismo se ha
reivindicado asimismo durante esta
pandemia
yo no sé si el periodismo se ha
reivindicado a sí mismo lo que creo que
el periodismo ha hecho lo que tenía que
hacer el periodismo profesional claro y
siendo blanco de críticas naturalmente
porque como el deporte nacional y yo
diría internacional es criticar siempre
al trabajo del periodismo a veces con
razón
resultó que demasiada información
confundía a la gente y entonces no
sabemos lo que nos dicen un día nos
dicen una cosa otros ya nos dicen otra
pero qué es lo que puede hacer un
periodista serio si hay un estudio
científico que demuestra que una vacuna
tiene una eficacia del 20 por ciento
comparada con otra que tiene del 90%
tiene que decirlo obligatoriamente y eso
crea desconfianza en el público hacia
una de las vacunas resulta que después
otro estudio científico dice lo
contrario que vamos a hacer no tenemos
que decir también yo creo que el
periodismo profesional ha hecho un
trabajo remarcable porque
porque no he visto en general
demasiadas salvo en situaciones en
países donde el problema de la pandemia
se mezcló con el problema de la
situación política y el problema
ideológico o el problema de un país
viviendo en una autocracia o ese tipo de
cosas entonces ya allí es mucho más
complicado porque el periodismo es un
periodismo muchas veces militante pero
el periodismo de oxy de de periodismo de
los grandes medios ha hecho realmente su
trabajo eso en el terreno de luisa en el
terreno de johann en el de las políticas
sanitarias como ha sido joan la relación
entre científicos y políticos porque el
conocimiento experto debe alimentar las
políticas públicas pero las políticas
públicas no pueden estar basadas 100% en
un criterio técnico no ha sido relación
tormentosas y es normal que sea así
porque porque de nuevo esta pandemia que
que ha hecho esta pandemia esta pandemia
ha acelerado los tiempos sociales la
ciencia es una práctica lenta es la
práctica del largo plazo esta pandemia
ha obligado a gente que no son
especialistas porque
no habíamos vivido una pandemia de este
tamaño yo creo que ninguno de los
científicos tampoco les ha obligado a
dar respuestas a muy corto plazo sin
tener forzosamente los datos la
experiencia etcétera entonces la ciencia
avanza por contradicción la gente yo
creo que lo aprendido ahora pero si la
ciencia avanza porque hay contradictores
que nos ponen en cuestión lo que hemos
dicho y nos fuerzan a buscar nuevas
respuestas no entonces la ciencia es
enemiga del corto plazo lo que nos ha
aprendido eso es que necesitamos tiempo
para la ciencia recursos para la ciencia
pública porque nos han faltado muchos
conocimientos sobre los cómics que había
científicos que investigaban sobre este
tipo de virus que no tenían recursos si
hubieran tenido recursos les podría
haber dicho más cosas luego tiene razón
tú los políticos hacen política ellos
tienen que basarse evidentemente en el
conocimiento científico pero basarse no
quiere decir absolutamente seguir ese
conocimiento científico han hecho su
trabajo de nuevo los políticos son un
trabajo hay más del corto plazo pero han
estado de nuevo sorprendidos por algo
que no conocíamos por algo que nos ha
superado por lo tanto una de relación
tormentosa que tiene que pensarse y
repensar se apagó porque creo que
qué tiene que tejer sea largo planeó
estos respeta a los políticos respecto a
los electores profesor lázarus creen que
los votantes y los ciudadanos miran a
partir de ahora más el tema del gasto
sanitario en los programas electorales
que se gasto en salud es el punto de
relieve más notable que saldrá de esta
crisis te has fuera se pregunta ojalá
que sea así es mi sueño que por fin la
población reconozca la importancia de
gastar más en salud pero no es sólo
gastar por gastar sino que está
eficientemente eso quiere decir preparar
para pandemias y frenar enfermedades
infecciosas como las expectativas de la
ética el vih aquí y también fuera de
europa
luisa habrá consecuencias en la forma de
votar las próximos soy incapaz de decir
si habrá consecuencias en la forma de
votar probablemente porque como vivimos
en un mundo de cortoplacismo entonces la
gente ir a votar en función de cómo le
pareció la administración de la pandemia
por parte del gobierno
ejercicio los últimos tres meses miremos
lo que pasó con angela merkel por
ejemplo el primer año de la pandemia
estaba controlada y entonces tenía 84
por ciento de opiniones favorables y
cuando la pandemia se desbarató en
alemania cayó cayeron esas opiniones en
40 por ciento es realmente fascinante el
mundo en el que vivimos y como la gente
cambia de opinión me quedo sin tiempo
hasta aquí muchísimas gracias a los tres
ha sido un placer estar con ustedes ya
todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana en
primera plana
[Música]